a nasty year comes to an end as we
examine the collapse of trust
in america's institutions i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben well before we get to anything going
on in the news
let me remind you it's pretty important
to defend yourself and there's a great
new way
for you to defend yourself i of course
i'm talking about taser
taser's line of non-lethal
self-protection devices they're small
they're lightweight enough to carry with
you or in your glove compartment or in
your purse they're powerful enough to
incapacitate an attacker i got one of
these for my wife i cannot wait for her
to start carrying it around because
frankly she's not a large person and i
don't want to rely on her powers
of self-defense in order for her to
protect herself this is why taser is
excellent they use an electrical charge
to immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds giving you time to escape to
safety
and it's an emergency dispatch to your
gps location they also have laser
assisted targeting you can protect
yourself and your family with taser's
line of smart
self-defense products again you know i
want a taser but i particularly want my
wife to have a taser
taser is also available without a permit
in most u.s states so if you live in a
blue state taser is like perfect
for you get the taser pulse plus or
taser strike light at taser.com with
promo code ben
say 15 right now at taser.com promo code
ben again
it is t-a-s-e-r.com promo code ben this
does make an
excellent christmas gift restrictions to
apply seasight for details again
go to taser.com promo code ben for 15
off and get yourself or somebody you
love a way to defend themselves that
is going to be legal in virtually all
states without a permit go check them
out right now taser.com
promo code ben alrighty so if the last
year has taught us
a couple of things it's taught us a
couple of things one the american people
are incredibly resilient like truly
resilient we have
this has been an awful year a truly bad
year hundreds of thousands of americans
dead of covet a political system that
has lost the trust of the american
people and i think
in many cases rightly so an
institutional
infrastructure in the united states that
has undermined our trust
in those institutions the american
people have withstood
all of this which is why i'm optimistic
despite all of that
going into next year because the
republic still stands and more
importantly i think that americans are
tough-minded
enough to have withstood this awful year
and moving forward
i think that there is every possibility
that things could get better in spite of
all the obstacles we face
but one thing has become clear above all
else in the middle of all of this and
that is
we need new institutions we need new
institutions or we need to remake
the institutions that currently govern
us i don't i'm not just talking about
the
the us government and i'm not talking
about the people who staff up
the administrative agencies in the us
government i'm talking about hollywood
i'm talking about the scientific
establishment i'm talking about social
media i'm talking about corporations
what we have watched over the past
couple of decades is the complete
remaking
of all the institutions in which
americans place their trust and in fact
the only institutions where the
constituency didn't really change
radically
those are the institutions that have
been under attack by the newfangled
institutions like the military and the
police right those are the institutions
that are under assault
all of the other institutions have
basically been hijacked by the power of
the left and militarized and weaponized
against you they've been militarized and
they've been weaponized by a group of
people
who truly believe that they are the
select
they are the elites they are the people
who should be running your lives
they speak a common language they look
down on people who do not speak the
common language
and they are willing to close all
avenues of power to people who do not
think
the way they think and the consequences
of their ideology are incredibly
dangerous
they no longer believe in the free
exchange of ideas many of them they no
longer believe
in individual freedoms and individual
rights they believe in a utopian scheme
whereby they get to effectuate equality
of outcome
above all else and i think americans
look at that and they rightly say i
don't trust these institutions that are
trying to cram down a version of reality
that doesn't exist on me
and then telling and then tell me that i
am some sort of heretic
if i don't go along in order to get
along in fact as i've been saying for
literally years at this point i think
that that's really what the trump
phenomenon is and was i think trump is
just a middle finger
to all of these institutions that
demanded your fealty while
simultaneously undercutting you
that demanded that you believe in them
that you repeat the nostroms that they
put in front of you
and then proceeded to use their
institutional power in order to undercut
a lot of your values
i think trump was just a giant pulsating
middle finger to that i think he
continues
to be that i think that's why he has
generated the enormous amount of love
from his base that he has
i think it's why he's generated the
enormous amount of hatred from the
institutional left
that he has but to understand how deeply
rooted
this battle is and what's going to
happen in the upcoming years and
this is where i think things are going
to get worse but i think the battle has
just begun i think that
no matter where we stand at this moment
and
no matter what happens when when joe
biden takes office in
in january in late january barring some
sort of cataclysmic occurrence
no matter what happens the battle is
going to continue and it's going to get
worse but i think the american people
are awake to the battle i think trump
has had a hand
in waking the american people up to that
battle trump was not elected
to govern is the reality trump was
elected in order to fight the culture
war
that's the truth of it if you ask his
people why they love him they don't love
him
because of the policy i know they're
wonks out there you know people like me
who like a lot of trump's policy
but the reality is that the reason that
trump has an outsized fan base
who are addicted and devoted to him is
not because of what he has done on taxes
it is not because of conservative judges
it is because he does fight the culture
battles and the culture wars
are the place that this country is
currently living it's going to be that
way until it's either weapons down on
the culture war by the left
or until the institutions themselves are
either demolished or alternatives built
or infiltrated by people who think
differently
what we are watching is a battle over
the institutions trump and the democrats
all that stuff is at the tip of the
iceberg right that is just the most
positive that is the most obvious
manifestation of this giant culture war
that has been roiling america
for decades on end it really does go
back decades but we have now reached i
think
the culminating point and frankly i
think it culminated
over the last couple of weeks with this
frankly unbelievable
unbelievable push by the cdc to tranch
out vaccines
by race i think that is the culmination
because if there's one institution that
americans should have
really ultimate trust in at this point
it is the institution of science
i don't mean science as an ideology
i mean that science is meant to simply
be
hypothesis and rebuttal it is meant to
be testing
and it's meant it's meant to be
falsifiability it's meant to just be
adding to the body of human knowledge by
asking questions and getting objective
answers and yet science has now been
hijacked in pursuit of politics
we have seen even that which has risen
above
disease made subject to the pursuit of
politics in a time
it really is sort of a microcosm of
where we are as a country and where we
are as a civilization
in a time when americans should have the
most trust they've ever had in the
scientific
establishment right we have developed
inside of nine months
the people who we hated most the
pharmaceutical companies inside of nine
months they developed
vaccines that are 95 effective in
preventing you from getting the disease
and apparently have beneficial effects
even if you do get the disease in
weakening the effects of the disease
that is a triumph of science greater
than any triumph of science
certainly since the the landing man on
the moon i mean it really is
that monumental a triumph of science we
have seen doctors and medical workers we
have seen nurses
going into hospitals with without proper
protection we see them in the hospitals
right now working extraordinary
shifts we see the hospitals packed to
the gills with people who have coveted
and we see our medical workers who are
out there fighting for life
each and every day and yet the amount of
trust that we have in our public health
experts right who are the
who are the scientific institutions
infused with politics
as at an all-time low and it should be
at an all-time low
because as with all other institutions
in american life
the scientific establishment has been
infused with a certain level of wokism
right the people who run our public
health establishment has been true since
the beginning
of the coveted pandemic when everything
became very political very fast
i was saying for months at the beginning
of the coveted pandemic i didn't
understand why covet had become so
political
we should simply follow the data and
then determine what was going to save
the most lives
and balance that out with what was going
to infringe on the fewest possible
freedoms and allow us to live
our lives as normally as humanly
possible while protecting the most lives
and that those should be the obvious
priorities of concern instead it turned
extremely political extremely fast and
became overtly political particularly
during the george floyd protests when 15
to 26 million americans went out in the
streets in the middle of a pandemic
and public health experts
epidemiologists from places like harvard
went out there and suggested
that it was perfectly okay for you to
protest for george floyd but it was
really bad for you to go to church you
couldn't go to a funeral for grandma
outdoors but you definitely could go out
there and shout about racial injustice
in the united states and they said this
in the name of science right
institutions get perverted and so as i
say
this this final sort of uh it is the
biggest story i mean there are a lot of
people today who are going to talk about
trump's pardons there are a lot of
people who are going to talk
about the the national defense
authorization act we'll talk about that
a little bit later on
in the show but the big story of the
last month is not any of the the stuff
that trump has been doing
because what will happen with that will
happen with that right either bills will
get passed or bills won't get passed
either trump will leave office
or or something cataclysmic will happen
but one thing has already happened
and it is indicative of a deeper problem
and again it's why you got trump because
trump as i've said about american
politics
basically since 2016. trump is the
coroner he is not the murderer everybody
wants to treat it as though american
politics is perfectly normal and
perfectly okay
until trump arrived on the scene that is
not correct
all of trump's heresies were
pre-approved
by the left he just came around and said
okay i'm gonna do it on behalf of the
right
okay but in any case the biggest story
of the honestly i think it's the last
several years
is the fact that the cdc was going to
tranch out life-saving care
based on race and then they wonder then
people wonder why don't you have trust
in the institutions why do you just want
somebody who's going to come in and
break things
because when you lose institutional
trust everything gets torn down to the
ground
so if you want to rebuild institutional
trust what you need to do
is stop infusing all of the institutions
with your politics
and you're starting to see this i think
this is why i'm optimistic i think some
people on the moderate left are coming
around to this i think some moderate
liberals are coming around to this so
yasha monk
who normally writes for the atlantic he
writes over
at uh at persuasion.community why i'm
losing trust in the institutions
he says who should be first in line to
get the vaccine against covenant 19.
these kinds of decisions are never easy
there are many competing considerations
highly trained moral philosophers can
have deep disagreements about them
though i myself have studied ethics and
political philosophy for much of my
academic career
i am deeply grateful i don't have to
make those judgment calls but for all of
those difficulties there are also some
bedrock principles on which
virtually all moral philosophers have
long agreed the first
is that we should avoid leveling down
everyone's quality of life for the
purpose of achieving equality
it is unjust when some people have
plenty of food while others are starving
but alleviating that inequality
by making sure that an even greater
number of people starve is clearly wrong
the second is we should not use
ascriptive characteristics like wraith
or race or ethnicity to allocate medical
resources
to save one patient rather than another
based on the color of their skin rightly
strikes most philosophers and most
americans
as barbaric the centers for disease
control have just thrown both of those
principles overboard in the name of
social justice
in one of the most shocking moral
misjudgments by a public body i've ever
seen
the cdc invoked considerations of social
justice to recommend providing
vaccinations to essential workers before
older americans
even though this would according to its
own models lead to a much greater death
toll
after a massive public outcry the agency
has adopted revised recommendations
but though these are a clear improvement
they still violate the two bedrock
principles of allocate of justice and
are likely to cause unnecessary
suffering on a significant scale
and then he goes into the details as to
how all of this happened
and how the how politics infused the the
entire consideration
here he says the cdc was effectively
about to recommend that a greater number
of african americans die so that the
share of african americans who receive
the vaccine is slightly higher right
this is what i explained yesterday and
the day before
on on the show i was pointing out that
if you benefit
20 year old essential workers who are
proportionately more black
over 60 over 85 year old grandmothers
who are proportionally more white you're
still going to end up killing an
absolute number of black people
more a higher absolute number of black
people because black people over the age
85 are still in that group of over the
age of 85 and they are the most likely
to die if you're a 20 year old black
essential worker
the likelihood of you dying is
extraordinarily low
so as yoshimung says in blatant
violation of the leveling
down objection prioritizing essential
workers in the name of equality would
likely kill more people in all
relevant demographic groups as criticism
of the recommendations mounted
epidemiologists mostly circled the wagon
but thankfully the pressure was too
strong to ignore
at a meeting that had before the
mounting controversy been expected to
rubber stamp the recommendations that
had already been unanimously accepted
the cdc changed course it now suggested
a more complicated scheme
once medical workers had received the
vaccine both americans over the age of
74 and essential frontline workers would
be vaccinated
in the second phase americans over the
age of 64 and the broader group of all
remaining essential workers would get
access to the vaccine
but this too is idiotic the reality is
that if you are going to look
at the actual proportion of people dying
from covet 19 it makes zero sense
to not trans older people before all
these essential workers
i was looking at these stats yesterday
by the way this is me not yasha monk the
coveted risk
is according to the cdc covered risk is
heavily striated by age according to the
cdc
the deaths are at the death rate of
covid for those above the age of 85
is 630 times the death rate for those
between the ages of 18 and 49
and 18 and 29 for those between 75
and 84 the death rate is 220 times
higher
for those between 65 and 74 the death
rate is 90 times higher so why
in the world would you be prioritizing
essential frontline workers who are 24
over people who are 67 right in one
group people are 90 times more likely to
die than in the other group it doesn't
make any sense
but again this is all social justice
woke-ism created by experts who are now
who are now going to cram down their
agenda on you so here's what yashimong
says he says
by disposition i trust the functioning
of establishment institutions and the
decent intentions of my compatriots
in a country with rapidly falling social
trust and growing political dysfunction
i try to hold on to my belief that some
key organizations are doing their best
until a few years ago it was obvious to
me i can trust what is written in the
newspaper or what i am told by public
health authorities
now i am losing that trust i still
believe that most people including the
journalists who write for established
newspapers and the civil servants who
staff federal agencies are the heroes in
their own stories they genuinely mean
well but i no longer trust any
institution in american life to such an
extent i am willing to rely on its
account of the world without looking
into important matters on my own
so yash monk is a mainstream liberal
right this guy's a democrat and he is
writing what i think many americans now
believe
it is not trump who's undermined the
institutions the institutions undermined
themselves and then trump pointed out
that they were hollow
that is what has happened over the
course of the last four years
as yahshua concludes the reasons for
this mistrust are perfectly encapsulated
in the reports the mainstream newspapers
published about the cdc's recommendation
the write-up in the new york times for
example barely mentions the committee's
last-minute change of heart
a faithful reader of the newspaper of
record would not even know that an
important public body was until it
received
massive criticism from the public about
to sacrifice thousands of american lives
on the altar of a dangerous and deeply
illiberal ideology
and this is right because the wokism the
speaking of the vocabulary the creation
of the new ruling class
that exists across institutions it is
not merely relegated
to the medical it is not merely
relegated to the cdc it exists across
institutions it's been perfectly evident
to people who have been watching closely
for the last several years it made
itself
incredibly manifest this year whatever
questions we had about our institutions
the institutions set themselves on fire
over the course of the last year
they set themselves on fire they doused
themselves in gasoline and they lit a
match
and going into next year that's going to
leave a choice for americans because
what the left is going to do is they are
now
with the with the power of the
presidency behind them when joe biden
takes office the electoral college has
voted
when that happens all of these forces
are going to be brought to bear in
double the strength they normally would
be
the reason that so many on the right
were invested in trump is because they
saw trump
i think in many ways correctly as the
man standing in the breach
they saw trump as the guy who was taking
on these institutions
they saw trump is the guy who's willing
to say the unstable sure sometimes he
said ridiculous things
sure sometimes he tweeted dumb stuff but
the reality is he was also saying things
that needed to be said in a way that
many republicans were shy
many republicans were shy to take on
these institutions trump was never shy
to take on the institutions
and a lot of republicans said okay you
know what that's good i'm glad that
we're doing that
so the question is if trump isn't there
and biden is in there
and biden is going to be standing behind
the institutional powers that be
and ramming them forward what are you
going to do to fight back what are we
going to do to fight back
i want to talk a little bit more about
the collapse of our institutional trust
and what it means
for the coming year what it meant for
the last year in just one second
first let us talk about your sleep
quality so
last night my baby she'd been sleeping
through the night she woke up five
o'clock this morning and she decided it
was time to party
the good news was that between the time
i went to bed and the time i woke up i
slept like a baby
which i need right the less sleep you
get the the better quality your sleep
has to be
helix sleep makes the magic happen so i
was at a hotel a couple of nights ago in
nashville
and i will tell you nice hotel right
perfectly good hotel but
the mattress was not my helix sleep
mattress i did not sleep as well helix
sleep it makes a mattress made
just for you they've got a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size folks so
if you are looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to
the mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't even need to
go to a mattress store like ever again
just go to helixsleep.com take that two
minutes sleep because they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
go check them out right now helix
sleep.com
ben for that very special deal okay so
what is the ideology
of the new ruling class the ideology of
the new ruling class
is that they are going to achieve
ultimate utopia via equality of outcome
the new ideology of the war of the
ruling class is wokism it's the stuff
that's taught at major universities
and so this this ideological poison
seeps into the bloodstream via the
universities the universities have been
completely taken over
by a radical left contingent that sees
human beings
in terms of group and seeks social
justice which is to say group justice at
the expense of individual justice that
believes that
americans can be categorized by race by
sex by sexual orientation
and then the coalition of the victimized
can
launch itself at the at the broader
superstructure of american society
in order to do that however you have to
renormalize america's institutions you
have to take over institutions that were
not designed
to cram down this divisive and
disgusting ideology
you have to take over those institutions
so how do you do that what you do
is you start off with a small core of
people who are extremely angry and
extremely loud
that is how you take over institutions
and there's a process that i've talked
about on the show before it's called
renormalization renormal and this is the
story again of the last 20 years
and it has accelerated radically over
the course of the last couple of years
really since 2010 i would say but
certainly in the last couple of years
since since trump took over
renormalization of the institutions when
trump became president there was an
open effort to take over institutions
that had not yet been taken over or to
radicalize institutions that were
already far to the left
all it takes is a tipping point a number
of people
in order to tip an entire institution
so renormalization theory which is a is
a term that was used by nissim nicholas
taleb
the author of the book black swan he
talks about how you can use a process to
basically
let a motivated minority count a larger
largely uninterested majority into going
along
to get along so talib in his book he
gives the example of you have a
vegetarian daughter in your family
and there are four members of the family
and so the vegetarian daughter can get
the entire family to eat vegetarian all
she has to do
is say i'm not going to eat a meal that
is not vegetarian you can eat what you
want but i'm only going to eat
vegetarian
now mom has a decision to make is she
going to cook two separate meals one for
everybody else and one for the daughter
or is she just gonna cook one meal and
everybody sort of goes along with it now
the entire family is eating vegetarian
because they love the daughter right
because she's an intransigent minority
right not a racial minority an
ideological minority okay now you can
take that family and you put them in a
block party with four other families
and that family says listen because of
our daughter we all eat vegetarian you
can eat what you want but
the reality is that the the we're not
going to eat
whatever meat dishes you make now the
person at the head of the block party
has to decide do i order two separate
meals
or is it easier for me just to order one
meal and everybody just eats vegetarian
so now
based on one person you have basically
20 people who are eating vegetarian you
can keep renormalizing up this way
right that's what you can do and this
applies in politics as in life so talib
writes in his
in his book he says you think that
because some extreme right or left-wing
party has say the support of 10
of the population their candidate will
get 10 of the votes no
these baseline voters should be
classified as inflexible and will always
vote for their faction
some of the flexible voters can also
vote for that extreme faction
these people are the ones to watch out
for as they may swell the number of
votes for the extreme party but it's not
enough to have one stubborn person you
have to have a tipping point
right you need to actually have a
certain number of people who are going
to go along in order to get along and
you have to have a certain number of
people
who are part of this hardcore coalition
so what the left has done is they've
created a coalition
they understand that in a company of a
thousand people there may only one be
one transgender person and if that
transgender person says
i demand that every single person in the
company start using preferred pronouns
and
that we declassify all the bathrooms the
other 999 people may say no we're not
going to do that
but if the transgender person can get
together with people who are in favor of
other
minority rights at the at the corporate
level and then they can form up
and now you got 20 of the population all
stumping for each other's causes right
this sort of
salt olinsky coalitional politics you
can take over an entire institution
there's a physicist named serge galam he
has posited that in some cases
only about 20 percent of a population is
needed to support an extreme view
in order to cause radical
renormalization
one way of creating an intransigent
minority coalition would be the
activation of what he calls frozen
prejudices at the risk of appearing
intolerant or a moderate to a broad
majority
while maintaining a solid core base in
other words you start with a more
motivated core group
you don't worry about who you alienate
you appeal to the prejudices of
other vulnerable groups and then they're
forced to choose between joining with
you
and their most ardent enemies people
they actually don't like okay so this is
what has happened inside corporations it
has happened inside hollywood it's how
hollywood somehow got more left
and over the course of the last few
years you now have the academy awards
declaring for example
that they are only going to give awards
based on whether the storyline
features protagonists who are of
particular race or particular sex or
particular sexual orientation
or whether a certain number of
supporting players are are of
these particular group dynamics you see
corporations
mirroring all this sort of stuff and you
see the media which has been completely
overtaken by
by woke-ism pushing this agenda
extraordinarily hard
okay so here's an example so
the the google is one of the biggest
companies on the planet google
has gone nearly completely woke right
several years ago
there's this whole controversy because
james damore who was working for google
at the time
he put out a memo about diversity inside
the halls of google in which he
suggested that maybe the reason
why he didn't have as many female
engineers is because women didn't tend
to go into engineering as much
or because if you look at test scores on
engineering women tend to occupy the
middle of the bell curve while men tend
to occupy
the tail ends of the bell curve right
and he was thrown out of google for this
a google has become completely woke
because they're so afraid of their own
employees they're afraid of being
perceived by the larger
group of americans as intolerant and
bigoted but more importantly they're
afraid of their own employees they're
afraid of their own staff
and you don't have to show evidence see
all you have to do is be intransigent
you don't have to show evidence that
woke-ism is true all you have to do is
insist that people cater to you and
people will begin catering to you
right this is what happens across the
political spectrum and it certainly is
happening on the left and it's happening
with regard to our institutions so
there's a
a story from hot air today
i'm talking uh about a former google
diversity recruiter
who quit and talked about how terrible
google is to black people
now that that is not true okay like the
idea that google is radically bad to
black people
the evidence on that is extraordinarily
scanty it didn't matter this woman whose
name is april christina curley
she announced on twitter this week she'd
been fired in september after six years
with google she worked as a diversity
recruiter her particular project was to
help google hire students straight out
of historically black universities
and colleges okay now immediately you
would say well that doesn't sound like
google is trying to racially
discriminate it sounds like
i mean at least not against black people
it sounds as though they're trying to
racially discriminate in favor of black
people
by specifically recruiting at
historically black colleges and
universities but
this person writes the reason google
never hired
an hbcu student straight out of
undergrad into one of their key
engineering roles
is because they didn't believe talent
existed at these institutions
until i showed up when i started at
google i quickly became aware of all the
racist bleep put in place to keep black
and brown
students out of their pipeline i
routinely called out shady recruitment
practices such as screening out resumes
of students with unfamiliar
schools or university names okay first
of all that is not a shady recruitment
practice
if i don't recognize the name of a
school and then i do recognize the brand
name of harvard
there's a certain level of sorting that
goes on when it comes to engineering
jobs where people immediately assume
that if you went to harvard
and i think rightly so that you are
probably of higher iq than a person who
went to the local
junior college that you've never heard
of right college is a sorting mechanism
that's basically all that it is
at this point but this person is too
busy accusing google of racism
and cruelty so she says every single day
for six years i fought tirelessly to
provide black and brown students the
opportunity to launch a career in tech
often i found myself arguing and
pleading with white women who lead
recruitment teams for internships and
full time roles
begging for students who are more than
qualified to be considered for offers
and then should because of my
adamant advocacy of black and brown
students to be fairly and justly
considered for roles at google i
experienced active abuse and retaliation
from several managers who harassed me
and many other black women
despite stellar performance metrics
which can be supported by multiple data
points
i was repeatedly denied promotions had
my compensation cut
placed on performance improvement plans
denied leadership opportunities yelled
at
intentionally excluded from meetings etc
the final finale she says f google f the
way google treats black women and black
people they do not want
black talent take it from me the most
successful black queer woman recruiter
who they fired in the middle
of an mf pandemic because they were
tired of hearing me call them out on
their racist bs this is the second
high-profile black employee to announce
leaving google this month okay the
backlash within the company led to a
group called the black googler network
meeting with alphabet ceo sunder pichai
with a list of demands regarding
all sorts of things you can watch the
renormalization of google
in process okay now they've already
re-normalized google is already a
far-left network right if you if you
google certain terms on google they've
already jogged their their search
results to come up with certain
left-wing ideas
okay but putting that aside this is the
way that institutions get captured
particularly corporations so
corporations are so deeply afraid on
every level
of being sued they're afraid of bad
publicity and because
they seek a uniform corporate culture it
is easier to make everybody uniform by
adopting woke-ism than it is to make
everybody uniform by rejecting woke-ism
and so you've seen the corporations
taken over every single day
every single day this year i've been
receiving notes from people who have
interviews
at top 50 corporations saying that
they're being asked questions like
what have you done to fight american
systemic racism
i'm sorry that has nothing to do with
being an engineer at google nothing also
it makes assumptions about the world
that simply aren't true
but better to mirror the crowd than to
actually stand up to the lie
right this is why americans don't trust
corporate institutions because they see
they see apple saying that it stands up
for woke-ism
simultaneously saying that it wants to
stand in favor of slave labor in china
they see lebron james suggesting that
america is systemically racist at the
same time that he is yelling
at daryl mori from the from the houston
rockets for standing up for freedom in
hong kong
we all understand the game here we all
understand that our institutions have
been perverted
to push certain political ends trump was
one middle finger thrown up at that but
i think more middle fingers
are to come because there is one big lie
that is told this is this is what
unifies the woke ideology the one big
lie is that america and the west are
terrible awful no good very bad places
and that all of this has to be torn down
to the studs and in order to do that
because that is an unpopular viewpoint
in america what you have to do
is you have to silence everybody there's
a silent majority in this country
they are being actively silenced okay i
can't tell you that honestly the number
of calls and emails that i receive
over the course of a given week from
people who say
i'm afraid of speaking up i'm afraid of
saying what i think is true
i'm afraid of saying it in a college
classroom i can't say it to my high
school friends
i can't put it up on social media and
we're not talking about saying awful
terrible things
we're talking about putting up pictures
of yourself at a fourth of july parade
we're talking about saying that
america's not systemically racist it's
stuff that most americans
tend to believe if you say that you
think it's bad to kneel for the flag
this is now considered
a breach of protocol the only way you
can get away with this is by silencing
and the way that you get away with this
by silencing
is by leveraging the institutions of
power on your behalf the right is not
incorrect to feel that it is under
assault from every major institution of
our society because it basically is
traditional and when i say the right i
don't mean small government
libertarianism
i mean social values i mean a certain
level of respect for american history
and a belief in deeply american
principles like individual rights
like constitutional rights like the
declaration of independence these things
are deeply controversial in today's
world
and if you signify your support for them
and your opposition to people who try to
tear them down
this puts you not only on the chopping
block it puts you at the risk
of being excised from polite society
that is what everybody has been feeling
over the course of this year the the
pandemic
only exacerbated this particularly in
the wake of the the racial protests that
we saw
but what we are living through is a
renormalization of all american society
via the institutions this has always
been a dangerous aspect of american life
right social
america relies a lot on social pressure
not just governmental pressure and now
we're getting it from both ends right
we're going to get a government that is
going to be fostering
this sort of institutional
discrimination against conservatism or
against traditional social values
or against even basic positive use of
americanism
we're gonna see that from from the
government but social life matters a lot
more than that
america because the government was small
historically always relied a lot on
social
on social pressure in order to in order
to force compliance with sort of social
norms
that could be good depending on what
social norms are being enforced the
problem is the social norms right now
are really really bad the ones that are
being enforced
alexis de tocqueville pointed out the
dangers of this going all the way back
to 1931.
here's what de tocqueville writes he
says under the absolute government of
one alone
despotism struck the body crudely so as
to reach the soul
and the soul escaping from those blows
rose gloriously above it but in
democratic republics
tyranny does not proceed in this way so
he's saying that if you look to the
tyrannies of europe
then what you see is an absolute
despotic government cramming down its
viewpoint on everybody else but people
tend to rebel against that he says in
democratic republics
that's not what happens he says it
leaves the in democratic republics
tyranny does not proceed in this way it
leaves the body and goes straight for
the soul
the master no longer says to it you
shall think as i do or you shall die he
says
you're free not to think as i do your
life your goods everything remains to
you but from this day on you are a
stranger among us
you shall keep your privileges in the
city but they will become useless to you
for if you crave the vote of your fellow
citizens they will not grant it to you
and if you demand
only their esteem they will still
pretend to refuse it to you you shall
remain among men you shall lose your
rights of humanity when you approach
those like you they shall flee you as
being impure
and those who believe in your innocence
even they shall abandon you for one
would flee them in their turn go in
peace
i leave you your life but i leave it to
you worse than death right that
what the tocqueville says there that is
what we are undergoing right now we are
undergoing
the the use of social pressure in order
to completely destroy not only all
social comedy
but any ability to dissent we have now
reached the point where by the way this
week
the former head of the aclu had an
amazing quote
so the former head of the aclu the other
day
he he put out a a statement
in which he talked with reason magazine
and here is what he says he says that
remember the aclu these are the people
who used to defend free speech
these are the people who used to believe
that even nazis should be able to march
through skokie right a heavily jewish
area in chicago
right ira glasser who is the former head
of the aclu here's what he said this is
this is the new america in which we live
he said he was visiting one of america's
top law schools quote
the audience was a rainbow there was
many women as men there were people of
every skin color and every ethnicity
it was the kind of thing we dreamed
about it was uh
so i'm looking at this audience and
feeling very wonderful about it
and then after the panel discussion
person after person got up including
some of the younger professors to assert
that their goals of social justice for
blacks for women for minorities of all
kinds
were incompatible with free speech and
that free speech was an antagonist
for people who today claim to be
passionate about social justice to
establish free speech as an enemy
is suicidal but here's the thing that's
not suicidal because social justice
is not actually in favor of free speech
it is not in favor of individual rights
it is in favor of you shutting the f up
right that is what the institutions have
been militized militarized on behalf of
this is why you are not allowed to talk
about the fact that america is not
systemically racist
in public places right i'm lucky i get
to do it for a living but if you say
that
in a corporate boardroom you'll get
fired if you say that at university
you'll get graded down and ostracized by
your classmates
if you say that even in the halls of
science
you will be shouted down for god's sake
the center for disease control is about
to trash out vaccines based on race
in a free country we're supposed to be
treated as individuals
so you're not wrong to feel like you're
under assault you were never wrong to
feel like you were under assault you are
under assault
you're under assault from hollywood
you're under assault from the scientific
community now you're under assault from
social media
which will shut down your ability to
even talk and get ready for that that's
that's going to be the big one next year
you're going to see a spate of
big name bannings this is something my
friend dave rubin has been pointing out
twitter is already talking about banning
trump
the minute he's not president you're
seeing it from corporations which is
most dangerous of all
but the most pervasive way you see this
is from the media the media have been
institutionally captured
and they pervert every one of these
other instances right so the media
have basically become an activist group
they're in the business of promoting
walkism in science they're in the
business of promoting woke-ism in social
media and cracking down on social media
and trying to prevent social media
from being able to disseminate ideas
that you like but that they don't
right this is why media has basically
devoted itself to trying to pressure
places like facebook and twitter
into canceling people they don't like
right it is the media who are driving
all of these narratives about why it's
good to protest
in favor of of defunding the police but
it's very bad to protest
in favor of being able to open your
business it is the media
who have been pushing hollywood even
hollywood to the left it is the media
who have been treating corporations as
evil and wrong-headed if they dare to
stand up
for their own ability to make money
right
so the first so how are we gonna fight
back that i'm gonna get to that in just
one second how we fight back here
because that really is the big question
we'll get to that in just one moment
first let's talk about an amazing gift
you can get somebody this holiday season
i'm talking about legacy box legacy box
is an effortless way to have your aging
tapes films and photos digitally
preserved
on a modern format so they are safe for
generations many of us have
irreplaceable moments on tapes on film
reels that we can no longer watch
your home movies they're like a time
capsule legacy box can help you open it
all that stuff down in your garage right
now it's molding it's falling apart get
it preserved right now i just did this
for my parents they really appreciated
it we went out to their garage we got
all their old film reels now
they have tape of us when we were kids
from you know vhs camcorders
and they have ta they have film reels
that have been transferred over to
digital of their own parents and their
grandparents
it really is amazing stuff go check out
legacy box right now the service could
not be simpler
use their kit to safely send the moments
you want preserved their team will
create a digital archive by hand
then you'll receive your new copies
stored on the cloud a thumb drive or dvd
along with all the original media you
sent them with their tracking system
you can monitor every step of the
process so you always know your
originals are being taken care of
over the past 10 years legacy box has
helped close to 1 million families
restore and protect their most cherished
memories
right now they're offering 50 off so you
can have everything preserved at once
for a fraction of the regular price
once you have these digital versions you
can relax knowing they will be secure
for generations
so even though it's last minute you can
still get the most meaningful gifts of
the holidays right now by going to
legacybox.com
shapiro take advantage of this limited
time offer get 50 off
take advantage of that exclusive offer
today use their kit now send it in
whenever you're ready go to
legacybox.com
say 50 while supplies last in a moment
we'll get to what we can do
in the next year because you know we're
getting to the end of the year what can
we do next year to fight back against
this because it feels
like all the guns are pointed in against
the views
that are traditionally american we're
going to talk about what we can do to
fight back
first daily wire is excited to announce
the historical docu-series
apollo 11 what we saw is now available
exclusively for daily wire members
originally released as an audio podcast
for apple and spotify what we saw takes
a detailed look at the apollo 11 mission
to land a man on the moon
it was the culmination of a heated
decades-long space race between cold war
rivals the united states and the soviet
union
the podcast explores one of america's
greatest accomplishments through the
eyes of the millions of americans who
lived through it
now apollo 11 what we saw is available
to watch as well as listen to over at
thedailywire.com
or on our apple tv or roku app the
series is just one piece of all the new
content we have coming down the pipeline
i'm talking about like a bevy of new
content we're talking about a new show
with candace owns that's coming probably
march
the entire prageru library is now
available behind our paywall we have a
brand new entertainment channel with
mainstream film
mainstream tv now let me just we have a
new investigative team now let me just
tell you i'm gonna make a
real pitch here okay all this stuff is
expensive it's expensive
to produce and to compete with the with
the establishment media that seeks to
destroy all the things you believe in
right investigative journalism is not
cheap entertainment is super not cheap
that means that we need your help if you
want to see somebody compete
if you want to see an alternative to
what you are seeing out there and you
don't like if you want to turn back the
tide
you should join the fight i mean you get
all this good content you get to enjoy
it but you're also helping out
become a daily wire insider or above
member for 20 off with code watch
over at dailywire.com subscribe make
sure to
get all of our content downl your big
screen including our podcast and special
live streams
that is dailywire.com subscribe to get
20 off your membership with codewatch
and access to all of our new
and existing content you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
so how do we fight back against this is
really the question because as i say i
think everybody feels it
by the way i think the people who are
who are even kind of mainstream liberals
feel this the reason that i know this is
that there are polls talking about how
many people
are afraid to speak up how many people
feel the pressure
not to say what they think and the
answer is an awful lot of them in fact
the only subgroup of americans who
believe that they get to say what they
believe on a regular basis are people
who consider themselves progressive
that is that is the only group of people
in america by polling
who feel that they get to say what they
believe so how do we fight back against
this
well first of all we're going to have to
rely on people believe it or not who are
moderate liberals who are sick
of watching the overton window shut now
at the beginning it's gonna be
self-preservation it's gonna be like
that harper's weekly letter that you saw
earlier this year where a bunch of
anti-trump liberals signed a letter
saying we don't like cancel culture
he's like you know what would have been
nice is if you had actually defended
people who you disagree with
not just you agreeing with yourself and
saying that you wish that you hadn't
been canceled
it'd be really nice if you opened up the
overton window a little bit wider
you're gonna have to rely on moderate
liberals but i think that coalition is
building
i think the backlash is building i think
that there is a there is there is now
cultural energy
behind the idea that there has to be
some sort of alternative here
and so there are a few things that we
can do right there there are a few
things that i think are actually pretty
necessary here to fight back and i think
that this is going to be the battle for
the next year
as people get thrown off of social media
as the as social media gets hijacked by
a biden administration as biden attempts
to use the power of government to cram
down his own particular
woke viewpoint and i know that he isn't
by nature well
he has adopted woke ism as his own
as this happens they're gonna be a few
things that have to happen one
conservatives are gonna have to take a
page from trump not in terms of
tweeting whatever trump tweets but you
have to embrace truth and not niceness
i know there are a lot of conservatives
out there who are worried that if you
speak truth it is not nice
it's one of the reasons why my slogan
has been for years now facts don't care
about your feelings that actually was
something that came up in the midst of a
discussion
about what sort of pronouns to use with
people and i was pointing out that
biological males are biologically male
and somebody said well you have to
respect the pronouns and i said well
facts don't care about your feelings
okay well facts do not care about your
feelings and we're gonna all have to
push forward with that attitude because
it is niceness that has been the chief
weapon
used against the right i think the right
knows this by the way it's why the right
is never going to nominate
uh john mccain remember mitt romney
again those days are over there's going
to be no more of this
civil this sort of civil concession
to the language of the left there's not
going to be any more premise accepting
from the right i think that is one of
the legacies that trump has had
but i think that that was going to
happen almost regardless it's why ted
cruz came in second right
so the fact is that niceness is going to
be rejected
in favor of standing up in favor of
virtue and here's the thing
standing up in favor of virtue is not
mean it is just
truth standing up in favor of virtue
does not mean that you are a jerk it
means that you are saying things that
are true and necessary
okay also you're going to have to engage
and convince right this is something
that we have not yet done
this means we do have to reach out to
people who are in the middle we do have
to reach out to suburban women who
turned away from trump in this last
election cycle we are going to have to
reach out
not just to to people who already agree
with us but increasingly we're going to
have to reach out with a conservative
message that speaks truth boldly
and and draws in stark colors to to
people who have not historically voted
republican
by the way that has a fact right trump
won and outside the number of hispanics
in the last election
cycle contrary to all previous opinion
he did really well
in texas with hispanics he did really
well in florida with hispanics
he want an outside share of the black
vote right as alienating as trump can be
speaking truth bluntly sometimes has an
effect and even if you say well yeah
trump didn't always speak truth right
trump said things that are false
i agree with you he said a lot of things
that are false but the underlying
message which is that the institutions
suck and are attempting to
drag you into their own ideology he was
not wrong about that and i think
everybody sort of got that right selena
zito had this formulation
early on in trump's in campaign where
they said people take trump
seriously but not literally and i think
that that has always been true i think
it will remain true because the serious
message underneath all of this
is that this stuff has to stop that the
assault has to stop
okay there's another tactic that the
right is gonna have to take
and this is a tactic i don't
particularly like but i think that we
are reaching that point
okay it's something that that i myself
pushed when i was the head of an
organization called truth revolt
my my business partner jeremy boring and
i before we ever launched daily wire
uh we were we launched a mission that
was sort of reverse media matters the
idea and we said it clearly
was mutually assured destruction because
here is the thing
if you can renormalize an organization
as large as google
simply by cobbling together a coalition
of the supposedly dispossessed
in order to renormalize from the inside
and you can exercise pressure from the
institutions like the media from the
outside in order to move
institutions if you can threaten
boycotts if you can threaten bad
publicity from one side and move the
institution
the right has a choice we can either set
it out and we can
and we can let the left do that or we
can fight back on the left's terms
and that means that if we see a company
that is now pushing leftism
we're going to have to use the same
means of the left not because we like
those means
i don't like those means i wish we
didn't have to do that but just like
with mutually assured destruction
where everybody wishes nuclear weapons
didn't exist the only thing worse
than you're uh the only thing worse than
you having nuclear weapons and your
opponents having nuclear weapons is your
opponents having nuclear weapons and you
not having nuclear weapons right
mutually assured destruction
kept the peace the reason it kept the
peace is because everybody knew it had
to be weapons down
otherwise everything would go up in
flames the right is gonna in some ways
have to become more militant not less
militant
militants on behalf of principle okay
not on behalf of personality
not on behalf of just yelling at people
but on behalf of principle
when corporations start cramming down
rob and d'angelo diversity classes
people inside the organization are going
to have to say no and they're going to
have to unify to say no and this is
really the key point
beyond everything else and beyond
everything else there's going to have to
be some level of solidarity that's built
up
it is not fair to ask individuals who
are inside institutions to stand up
as i said before if the ratio is a
thousand to one against you you standing
up just gets you fired
we're gonna need to start coalition
building we're gonna need to start
building
communities of people who are willing to
come out together and say no we are not
going along with this
no we are simply not going to do this
and we need to provide
safe haven for people who do get fired
from these sorts of positions
we need to provide defense mechanisms
for people who stand up and get clubbed
on the head
and that means the building of
alternative institutions that means we
need
an alternative media for people who are
ousted from traditional media for
speaking the truth
it means that we need an alternative
hollywood structure where people in
hollywood who disagree with the
prevailing wokism of hollywood
have a place to go and get their movies
funded and we need to patronize those
movies we need to make sure that people
actually watch that stuff
we need to make sure that if you are in
the scientific establishment and you are
out
and you are ousted for the grave sin of
saying something biologically true
that we provide a soft landing for you
that we provide a landing spot for you
and one of the great mistakes that the
wright made is that they always assumed
that
institutions beyond college would shape
the people coming out of college
right college we understood that
colleges shape the students
and they shaped them toward woke
philosophy but we also assumed that they
would get out in the real world they'd
go work in corporate land they would get
a job they'd pay taxes and eventually
they'd get more conservative
and there was some truth to that but
statistically speaking what has now
happened here
is that people exited college and
instead of the institutions shaping them
they shaped the institutions and then by
grabbing power at the institutions
they use the institutions to create
widgets of themselves
to silence everybody there is a majority
in this country that still believes that
america is the greatest country ever
conceived there's still a majority in
this country
that believes that america is not
systemically racist and is filled with
good people who want to treat each other
decently
that still believe in human virtue and
believe in individual rights
there's still a majority in this country
who's willing to go out and work hard
every day and believes
that that work is good for the soul in
many cases and that we shouldn't be
incentivizing people to stay home
there's still a majority of people in
this country who basically want to be
left alone
and most of all there's a majority in
this country that still wants to stick
together but in order for us to stick
together we're actually going to have to
now
create structures for us to stick
together because as benjamin franklin
said it
at the at the outset of this entire
project either we uh hang together or we
hang separately
that is where things currently stand so
we got to make the choice ourselves
right now this next year is going to be
the test are we going to hang together
or are we going to hang separately it's
easy to splinter in the face of
overwhelming pressure
when things look bad when the white
house moves to the democratic party it's
easy to get discouraged
don't get discouraged get to fighting
because next year is going to be the
fight
the fight didn't start with trump it
didn't end with trump it's going to
continue now and as the left pushes
harder and harder
that just means the right is gonna have
to come up with better strategies and
push back harder
in every arena not just with regard to
voting but with regard to every cultural
institution there is we're gonna have to
push back we're gonna have to push back
hard and if we do
i think that we're still the majority
and i think that we'll win okay so
before we break i just wanted to um
bring you
a couple of minutes of something
inspiring so one of the things that we
have done here at daily wires we put
together a fantastic series called
apollo 11
what we saw it is a it is a review of
the the greatest achievement in human
history perhaps putting a man
on the moon in terms of technological
expertise
it is it is unparalleled in the annals
of history obviously and
bill whittle was the host of that
particular program for us it is now
available if you subscribe over to daily
wire you can get a roku and apple tv
it's a beautiful program to watch we did
these beautiful visuals that go with it
including all of the old footage it's
great to watch with the family it's an
inspiring thing to watch going into the
new year
so go over to dailywear.com subscribe i
talked to bill a little bit about it
here's what that sounded like
alrighty well i thought that now was a
great opportunity right before
christmas it's a great time for you to
go to subscribe over at dailywire.com
subscribe one of the reasons that you
should do so is because we have a series
it's called apollo 11 what we saw the
host is
bill whittle we brought it out on audio
a while back but it's a beautiful video
series and now it is available on apple
tv
or roku for our subscribers it's amazing
to watch
bill thanks for joining the show great
to talk to you great to be here ben and
as somebody who's still in california i
just want to let you know there's less
and less to miss every single day
i really appreciate that i think that
after having done the apollo 11 series
actually the moon might be a better
place for you than california in the
very very near future
so let's talk about the apollo 11 series
that you did why do you think that that
story is still important for today
well especially given the trends of the
last uh six seven weeks or so
you can make a pretty compelling
argument that uh july 20th 1969 was the
pinnacle of human history
uh it may end up being that way that may
have been as far as we've gone it may
have been the boldest thing that we did
the most
ambitious thing that we did i like to
think it's not
but certainly as far as history to this
point goes
it's the most remarkable achievement in
the history of the human species
and one of the things that you do in
your apollo 11 series is you put it into
the historical context it wasn't just a
scientific achievement
it was also a political achievement
considering that it really was part and
parcel of this massive cold war that we
were having with the soviet union at the
time
it's exactly right and um it was a
subset of the cold war
when you had a 42-year conflict where
you know the
nuclear weapons tend to deter people
just running off the handle a little bit
it gave both sides an opportunity to
compete for world opinion
and it gave them an opportunity to to
compete with
pretty much with the hardware that the
that the militaries of both countries
had put together certainly in the early
stages the boosters on both sides were
intercontinental ballistic missile
boosters
and the whole thing was about technology
and as we talked about in in the first
episode just
the raw shock of sputnik of having a
russian
satellite over it head and then just a
few months later they put up sputnik 2
with a dog a dog died a few hours into
flight so you got to think
here i am an american and in 1957 58
there's a dead communist dog flying over
my house
four or five times a day that that tends
to focus your mind in an age of
thermonuclear warheads
so bill little one of the things that
that i think is is fascinating about
where we are sort of in modern life is
there is this feeling that we may be
embarking on a second space age this
time led by some folks in the private
sector like elon
musk and spacex what what is the
continuum in terms of you know america's
focus on the stars here
uh well the uh work that the
private um space companies are doing is
remarkable and this is the space age
that america really should have
it's a it's a free market space age it's
uh i hate to use this word sustainable
but it's it's economically
sustainable they're doing it for a
profit which means that they don't get
to pull the rug out from under our feet
there was an apollo 18 19 and 20 that
were built
stacked ready to go and they were simply
cut by congress so
we don't have to worry about those kind
of things with with a private company
all of the great aviation companies like
lockheed boeing
uh hughes northrup we're all based on
individual companies run by individual
men who decided this is
what i want to do and elon musk is doing
that my only concern right now ben
is that donald trump had put together an
entirely new looking nasa
and that nasa was a hands-off nasa that
was
predicated on allowing the private
sector to get into space and do the work
they've always wanted to
now we're hearing talk about cooperation
with china
and we're hearing talk about um you know
all sorts of
making everything an economic and racial
issue and
and that is the only thing that worries
me about the space
program as it exists today musk is
amazing because he understands
that in this in this era since we don't
have the the russian threat over our
head
he he understands how important it is to
make things
just plain fun i mean the launch of
starman and
a red tesla sportster and david bowie
and don't panic from hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy and then those
twin boosters uh landing together uh
as i say in in the series i saw the moon
landing when i was
10 from the uh plaza hotel in new york
and when neil armstrong said that's one
small step for a man one giant leap for
mankind there was a
roar just this roar came up from central
park and i haven't heard the like of
that since
until i heard the reaction to those
crowds when those two boosters on spacex
falcon heavy came back down it was that
same sound so that gave me a lot of hope
well folks you should definitely check
out apollo 11 what we saw you should
check it out visually because
while it is a great audio podcast it is
much better visually you can actually
see all the images
uh you can you can see how beautiful the
production values are go subscribe over
at dailywire.com
subscribe and go check that out makes a
great christmas gift for someone bill
great to talk to you
great to see you ben you're doing great
work out there we'll talk to you soon
alrighty folks so we have reached the
end of the year but don't
be discouraged the fight is only
beginning we'll be here with you next
year
hang in there have a good holiday stay
safe out there i think the next year is
going to be a great year i don't think
it's being a good year i think it's been
a
great year i think that covet is going
to come to an end i think that we're
going to fight back
i think that we are going to create
alternative institutions i think we're
going to fight back against the
institutional power leveraged by the
left i think this is the beginning of
the resurgence i don't think this is the
the beginning of the end i think it's
the end of the beginning and now we get
into the real battle
all righty later today michael knowles
hosts the michael moles show will be
guest hosting two additional hours of
content make sure to tune in for that
have a wonderful christmas have a great
new year we will be back on air january
4th i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel our associate
producers are rebecca doyle and savannah
dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020
president trump pardons political allies
npr names wap
the song of the year oh boy and just 49
of americans believe the coronavirus
vaccine is safe check it out on the
michael knowles show
you